oh shut up you're the nasty son of a
[ __ ]
i don't need this like the son of a
[ __ ] oh you're an ugly son of a [ __ ]
son of a [ __ ]
son of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
angela cursed michael out so bad
it wasn't even funny i am that [ __ ]
your mama warned you about
after attempting to put a tracker on his
phone angela took things to the extreme
and eventually called it quits with her
husband listen
i should have left you when i went there
and your penis wasn't what you said it
was
you lied from the beginning michael
hopefully this warning isn't too late
and i apologize if it is
but please get your kids out the room
and prepare yourselves emotionally and
mentally because this relationship is
over
we're gonna talk about it plus she might
learn some tricks
mike and natalie bought a pet rat yep
a rat while people try to keep rats
outside the house they brought one in
i mean she's really smart and beautiful
and clean and her name is
lucky i'll tell you why they made this
unusual choice
and also break down how things are going
now that they're back and squint
whatever you do she will still say about
you post natalie's confrontation with
mike's mom
my mom just said the point is my mom
said like
my mom was very nice you're just saying
my mom's bad and i was not raised right
natalie in this rat on her shoulder is
definitely
giving me villain vibes hey i guess
rats need love too quit seeing stupid
all right let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia
we have a lot to talk about today when
it comes to angela
but i want to start off on a positive
note because we need
it we need the positive juices flowing
before we get into this mess
[Music]
[Applause]
i just can't help but notice how she has
the most adorable relationship with her
grandkids
let's try this they were so cute tasting
the smoothies that she has to drink now
because of her weight loss surgery nema
makes the best dumplings but terrible
smoothies well this little one in the
red has to disagree
look at her rocking out they really
bring out the best
in angela i am that [ __ ] your mama
warned you about but
i cannot say the same thing about her
relationship with michael
that thing it brings out the worst
i went to see a hypnotist to stop
smoking and
i didn't want a cigarette after i left
hypnotherapy
and then i start thinking about that son
of a [ __ ] and husband of mine
he's definitely the main trigger
of my smoking huh now i'm back to
smoking
i pack a day because of him as we
continue on
there's a running theme in this episode
of angela blaming michael
for her own actions and honestly that's
not just this episode
that's more like a running theme we've
seen throughout our entire storyline
but this time around she takes it to a
new level
since my surgery michael has been acting
shady angela went to an i.t
shop to attempt to put a tracker on
michael's phone because he hasn't been
calling her lately
now just for some context a few episodes
ago
michael did make it clear why he was
giving angela the cold shoulder
before our wedding angela and i decided
to
share our finances together he shared
that they plan to split their finances
but instead angela has been spending a
lot of money on these surgeries
not even considering the fact that he
still wants a baby
since andrea wasn't listening to me
regarding a surgery i started giving out
the silent treatment
and it's so difficult but i wish my wife
she would at least respect my opinion
sometimes you know make decisions
together for some reason angela's not
hearing that
i am that [ __ ] your mama warned you
about remember that he doesn't pick up
the phone and she
automatically thinks cheating which she
could be doing
but she also doesn't consider the fact
that he has the right to be mad
too for her actions my husband's in
nigeria oh okay
and i'm here in america okay and he's
been acting shady lately
he just vanishes okay
so just so you know we cannot spy on his
phone why not
because it's illegal
and then she came with this excuse he's
the one making me have to do this
michael is not your 16 year old son who
just got his driver's license
he's not making you put a tracker on his
phone but
somehow she convinced herself that he is
okay
so show me how i'm gonna hack my
husband's phone okay so like i said we
cannot hack it
but how do you communicate with him
what's up the it guy went on to tell
angela
that the only way she can track
michael's location is if he gives her
access
when is that done you have he had to
click send and you can see where he's at
that is all the options we got
legally yes well what about we don't do
illegal
uh i won't be able to help you with that
whatever paid double
angela you're on camera this is the
second time
i've noticed her asked someone to do
something that could potentially ruin
their life
while being filmed and i'm gonna use my
southern charm
to see if i can get that faceless
surgery first time she thought she could
talk the doctor into giving her a
facelift
even though she's been smoking i don't
want to have that liability on my side
and now the i.t guy that definitely was
the first for me
who by the way is about to get real
uncomfortable i feel pissed
he is about to see a side of angela that
i don't think anyone
deserves to experience you know what
let's try it now
okay that's fine why you're here that's
fine angela calls michael to ask him
in the most aggressive way possible to
give her access to his location
you mind cutting on the location on your
don't talk to me like that after
watching what happens next
i literally had to close my mouth you
know what you know you're a woman so
well you don't know me worth it
oh shut up you're a nasty son of a [ __ ]
see i'm calling you [ __ ] i do that
openly you're the one that's the nice
guy
i never claim to be tonight's [ __ ] i am
that [ __ ] your mama warns you about
remember that
i'm loose mouth remember um don't you
tell me how i can talk she wants to
overtalk me scream at me and make me
snap and go to custom this is not who i
fell in love with
why are you talking to me like that why
is he talking to you like that
angela you're the one doing the talking
i'm the american tribal [ __ ] remember
everything she accused michael love he
wants to over talk me is exactly what
she's doing
this is the man that conned me to marry
him look
he's laughing while i'm getting pissed
off angela she just started yelling the
moment that he answered the phone
i really didn't even hear his voice i
don't know what he say the fights are
right away so
and the fight got worse i got too many
killing commands outside there sitting
around me i don't need this like the son
of a [ __ ]
listen the i.t guy might be laughing but
what she's saying is emotionally abusive
son of a [ __ ] son
[Music]
handsome man that's why you had to get
online and manipulate me
angela was being so childish we've seen
her go off before
but i've never seen her act like this
and if she's telling michael he is all
of those things
you're the nasty son of a [ __ ] what
does that make her
take you up how wild this situation is
might be funny but all jokes aside
i want to see angela be better than this
she's talking about how michael doesn't
show her love at this time but
who wants to be affectionate to someone
who speaks down to them like that if
that was me
you wouldn't be getting any of my loving
okay
i am out the door i'm the crazy [ __ ]
i'm a good crazy [ __ ] there's a
difference although i get what she's
saying
that still doesn't make acting crazy
okay and yeah
michael stood up for himself in that
moment but later on that night
when she called him he was trying to get
back on her good side
which is a sign that he either does not
value himself
or he just wants to get to america it
could be both
you've gone too far and i really have no
feelings for you at this moment
you got i'm not your dear i just don't
have no feelings for the way you treated
me
you need to be with somebody that's
stupid and desperate you're an idiot and
you're a joke
and you're not for me excuse me no why
would you uh
let's stop right there let's not let's
let's not act like
my dear and the british she said let's
not act like my dear
and the british let's not act like my
dear and the british
that was funny but she went on to call
michael out
on a completely different level
listen i should have left you when i
went up there and your penis wasn't what
you said it was
you lied from the beginning michael is
anyone else impressed
by michael's composure because i'm sure
there are a lot
of things he could have said about her i
am positive
but he didn't and i never thought i
would say this but i
hope it's because he wants to get to
america and not because of low
self-esteem
i hope he's taking all of this because
he wants to cross the atlantic ocean
okay goodbye we're done angela proceeded
to hang up on michael
my dear and thank you and after all that
she said
what do you want to discuss he still
caught her back
that's when she ended her relationship
with michael
and i did this because angela ends her
relationship with him pretty often
listen michael i ain't guess they
married somebody i don't want you that
mistreats me
none of your business none of your
business
oh yeah angela is not wearing this scarf
because of covid
she actually had an infection in her
mouth at the time which she also blamed
on michael
i noticed every time me and michael
having these arguments and all i have an
abscess that breaks out
anyhoo back to the breakup this
relationship is over
i know that'll get you okay see you
later
you know when i tell michael okay well
i'm gonna cut my ties with you
and he's like okay he's not gonna beg me
well that one's like someone that loves
a person to me is it you
it's so interesting how she dogged him
but still expected for him to suck up to
her
that's just not how it works if you want
to receive
love that's what you have to give
speaking of that let's move on to
natalie who
always wants respect but
has a hard time giving it to others i
don't know if he trained her but
she's nice this episode she and mike
bought a pet
rat here's how that happened
funny story um
[Music]
it's like that uh we went into a feed
store to
look for some puppies and this lady came
in and was like let me get two rats and
uh now he's like what are you gonna do
with those and she's all
feed him with my snake so natalie was
like oh my god michael we gotta save all
the rats
i was like no no you could take one i am
not a rat person but the gesture was
sweet
i just wish natalie could be just as
kind and compassionate to mike
as she is to the right it's been about a
week since myanmar
came from oklahoma and we still haven't
talked about that huge argument
natalie is referring to the argument
that happened after she accused mike's
mom trish of calling her a hooker
she looked at me and i was cooking
and she said hooker no no one did not
call you a hooker
no one calls you a name there's always a
misunderstanding
it's the same thing no matter where we
go no matter who we're talking to you
hear one word
you take it as they're telling it to you
the annoying part about this
is that i don't think we're ever gonna
know whether or not trish called natalie
a hooker
i don't think she would i don't see her
as that type but
i also don't know the lady so right now
is trisha's word against natalie's
and based off of natalie's track record
it's easy to believe that trish didn't
call her that
and she just heard wrong you know we
talked to my mom and
for mother who raised your child good
and proper way it's kind of hard to hear
but so what i'm a bad child my mom's a
bad mom
i can't tell you when she does what you
just that's what you just said so my
mom's a bad mom
my mom just said the point is my mom
said like
whatever natalie have your mom ever joke
to your ex-wife
there must be a part of natalie that
enjoys drama
because there are so many other ways she
could have had this conversation with
mike my mom
was very nice you're just saying my
mom's bad and i was not raised right
because your mom's so good and raised
you right you're basically putting my
mom down right now
stop i asked my mom what should be off
i've learned
in relationships and older couples will
tell you this
there is a moment during an argument
where you could either choose your ego
or you could choose peace but for some
reason natalie keeps running with her
ego
and mike is about to tell her about
herself i work really hard for my
diplomas and you know what your mom said
to me
she said it doesn't matter what you
study six years you gonna be
translated like your mom said she didn't
say that no she didn't
she said you should be a translator
during the pandemic until you can go
pursue your dreams
just wanted to clear that up was that
what me and my mom were suggesting to
you
wow you literally never listen
it's only what you want natalie like
there's no point in talking to it
because you just want to do what you
want to do
and you're going to step over everyone
in your path and it doesn't
matter i will not step over my morals
this is for sure right
but you'll step over but you'll step
over me and everyone else i will not
step over my morals
right your morals yes none of us are
perfect but i would love
to know what natalie's morals are i'm
curious
she eventually apologized okay okay
i'm sweating but mike was over it and
next week
it looks like somebody is leaving what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
you cannot sit there and tell me why you
love me
or why i'm important michael are
important to me but you're neglecting me
get with the program or get out
[Music]
you're in or you're out i'm not strong
probably for this
all right 90 day fans fam so make sure
you stay updated on that situation
plus all the latest news coming out the
90 day universe
make sure you stick with e.t because we
are covering it all
i will see you next time
[Music]